hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
now this time we're going to be doing
something a little bit different I will
be doing the 100 Mario challenge and if
you play this before you might have
played the 10 Mario challenge but this
one is going to be more difficult see
I'm gonna start off with eight levels
and I'm gonna play it on normal first
and if I can get through these in 100
Mario's which should be perfectly easy
because I don't imagine they're going to
be incredibly difficult on normal see
there's different rankings there's easy
normal expert and then super expert in
their different ranges of percentages
that the people who made them usually
complete them when they played expert
being the top 10% or only 10% of people
who play it finish it super expert being
like under 1% of people who actually
play the levels actually finish the
levels so starting on normal I believe
that's 50% to like 15 50% attempt like
20% I don't know what it is but mario
has made a hundred clones of himself
holy crap what are we looking at here oh
isn't hey what are you going off like
little Rockets for it's not cool ah stay
away you're just charged into your own
death I didn't have anything to do with
that one so these shouldn't be too
incredibly difficult here and actually a
lot of you guys requested this
particular what the hell is happening a
particular challenge oh this is easy I
duns did it dudes did if I didn't miss a
thing so I'm gonna take me and my
hundred clones which I imagine that's
what Princess Peach does when she
manipulates everyone in her kingdom
because I've read or I've watched the
game theorists about Mario I've done the
thing with the thing in the thing and I
know that there's a certain certain evil
type of mushroom II fungus that's
dominating the entirety of the Mushroom
Kingdom I'm actually taking over it's
people watch it it's very creepy to
learn about the secrets behind Mario but
in this it's gonna be a-okay alright
what do we got whoa whoa whoa whoa
and the good benefit about this is that
Oh God ah tits well there goes one of my
clones good I think I got 99 backups
ready to go
Mario falls down pass it around okay so
so spoopy oh that's a giant thrusting
dildo oh my god I've never seen that
before I mean I think I've seen it in
like the original Mario Super Mario
World but Wow did not expect giant dildo
to be exploding out of the ground there
ow my face stop it with the party it's
not time for that holy crap okay hello
oh that's slightly weird and it's an
extreme party here and I'm oh my god oh
we got Oh wha ha ha why is this a
haunted rave mansion and where the hell
am I going thank you thank you thank you
for this to win the development what
what I'm always wondering is like when
the developers who oh good
when the developers were making this
like like this particularly Bob chilly
out here
no thank you I don't want a bunch of
angry wigglers coming on down the road
okay am I supposed to need this for any
particular reason
okey dokey then never mind goodbye hello
goodbye Oh goodbye hello goodbye oh gosh
oh god oh god oh gosh okay I think we're
fine just gonna spin the victory here
the other good thing about this
challenge is that it allows me to see a
lot of different levels very quickly
holy crap what is wrong with you Oh
a little more
oh I don't need you I need the feather
thank you
oh why how could you do that to me why
would you bat me around so much this is
insanity oh how am I gonna be able to
get it back good okay
just barely should I go up or through
the door oh crap
yeah there we go yeah there we go okay
oh my gosh ah no ah titties it's not
what I want to do probably not something
I should say when I'm playing Mario hip
kooky I'm gonna go through the door just
to see what it is okay what is that a
key up there how am I supposed to be
able to do that is that gonna benefit me
anyway
how do I do any of this where am I going
I was so lost I have a really bad
feeling that whoa-ho
that would have been bad could and it
very badly from I have a feeling that
it's just leading me astray and I'm not
ever gonna get to the end of the goddamn
level here okay oh my that was a key up
here I don't know what oh I need to find
five keys how am I gonna be able to do
that oh gosh I can't get through there
can i oh no can't damage boost oh god
that was a mistake
it won't be here anything the water Oh
Oh God oh so far I don't know I was
supposed to go ah crap okay holy crap if
a course is too difficult you can pass
on it by touching and sliding with the
stylus you can also pass by holding the
- I'm gonna pass on this one just
because holy crap if I needed to find
five of those key things I wasn't even
close to finding exactly what I needed
okay off on the way to another level
here oh oh that's not happy come on come
on come on
okay see the skin us meant to be a troll
can I take this with me do I need this
what am I do with this nothing
I'm not I'm not sure I'm not sure
someone put a lot of thought into the
level design here it sounds like someone
just like went crazy with the stylus and
just hope for the best
unless I need that turtle all the way to
the end which would be a really really
douchey move I'm gonna be able hey yeah
there we go
whoa okay Bastien a keys damn it come on
stop being ridiculous I always hate it
with like you go over to the new Mario
World and it's just completely different
controls in the end you know oh hello
again
really seems like someone just kind of
went willy-nilly with the blood with the
brush they're way different than the
very interesting varied and dynamic
ghost level that also seemed like it was
made by someone on a didi but that's
besides the point we got to get through
x' we got a lot more levels to go let's
go what do you got for me this one's
made by that was either Korean or
Japanese I couldn't quite tell I've
never seen one of these in this level
okay got it
where am I going was I supposed to go to
the door hello oh my goodness
sorry I entered Oh God I didn't go into
the right neighborhood there okay come
on we can do this I don't know if we can
do this one I'm just gonna assume that
we can't because of the alternative is
not doing it where does this go hello
oh well that seems hardly fair I'm not
gonna take the Chiti way out of that one
I'm gonna actually try to do it the
strategically good way I don't know if
I'm gonna succeed in doing that but at
least I'm gonna try so if I just go
straight through this budget god damn it
okay if I go straight above them and
then go straight through it I shouldn't
be able to slide right on by if I don't
go too high they says my theory anyway
I'm gonna revisit just for the design of
it when there's something that it spells
out in the middle in Korean or Japanese
hey bombs by bombs okay they're not
gonna hurt me oh I'm gonna hurt me
you're not gonna hurt me oh no oh no oh
no oh no
oh why would you do this okay I can make
this yeah oh well nevermind then
I can't make that well I was close to
the end I suppose okay so I just need to
not do that the certain ones hidden in
the clouds that bounce you up I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna stay back you know
I don't need to be in there right away I
can just watch everyone fall to their
doom and then go about my business
without being bothered in any capacity
by them okay create on through nice and
easy nice and easy there we go
oh it's a big star but what's the point
of that huh what's to pouring it out
there I don't know but I think we're
gonna make it okay
hey okay we made it that was pretty good
I mean I don't know what the point of it
was but I got it so that's good all it's
halfway there we're gonna make it we
only burn through nine clones I mean
they're expendable everywhere anyway
they don't even have feelings
they're just Mario's oh ah ah okay um I
was a beginning to think those Rosses
level words just run OH
oh okay alright then I guess okay all
right cool I can make it you know I'm
down for it I'm down to climb with that
one I'm not opposed to just having it
easy I'm not opposed to having it handed
to me even though I missed the world
record by that much but I'm pretty sure
that I wouldn't have been able to get it
anyway alright go on this clones really
getting it good
two three Yoshi's Island is this like
actually supposed to be Yoshi's oh nice
all right so what am I supposed to do
about this
uh-huh BRR ah [ __ ] no come on Yoji
you're still a slave yo Z stop it so far
so good
really elegant about this whoa hello
who's doing that yep okay I don't know
where this is going but I'm hoping it's
gonna be a bonus well that that doesn't
help me at all unless is actually
supposed to be like Yoshi's Island
whoopsies rap I don't think I was
supposed to go down there I missed out
on Yosh Yosh oh boy this is this is
awkward hey everybody down there how you
doing oh look another one up it is oh my
gosh this is Yoshi's I just realized I
just realized what level just was this
is literally Yoshi's Island which is one
of my favorite games I played it on a
live stream I love all it is holy crap
it's just a recreation of Yoshi
that is so cool it's really cool it is
it even as the flying coins which is
like a big feature of it I don't have my
yo spit
oops didn't know it clear at all you
guys blue all right good enough oh I
know I can point there we go got it
I'm an to win the baby and to win it
wink there we go another Yosh
I think oh that's that's not what I want
it okay we're good good good we're good
[ __ ] we're good we're good BAM okay got
it
okay we're good oh we're almost there
we're almost halfway through this this
is fun this is like really fun I don't
know why I wasn't playing 100 Mario
challenge earlier because this is really
good because it sees a lot of levels and
it does give me a lot dying to much but
I can't I do want to get to the over to
the expert ones because the expert ones
are gonna be a bit tricker and hopefully
they're gonna be a little bit better for
me because that way they're more
interesting and I get a bit more of my
epic skill into it because everyone
knows that when I play Mario maker I'm
incredibly epically its killed and I
just realized oh yeah the 1ups do do
something because when you're playing on
them high
well then you know some of them are good
level some are not as good as the other
one but when I just grabbed from the
entirety of online randomly I guess
gonna have some truly ones and I just
realized the 1ups actually do do
something in this game because you up
you obviously get more 1ups and they add
to your collection of clones so that you
keep going sorry I got the hiccups oh
god oh god oh god oh god win oh god I
was totally caught off guard by that
well like companion spring heaven where
all the companion Springs that you've
burned up in the previous versions of
Ross's levels this is where they go to
die
alright just one more baby one more and
then the princess is mine I will survive
the fire fight it's called Oh
I have never ever ever ever ever seen
what is this oh my god is this was this
added in an update or something because
before I could play this game to add in
an update but what the hell it's so cool
it's even got the spiky dildos and it's
got the luchador oh my god it's just up
come that's so cool it upgraded its
cannon what the hell it's ash mop it's
turning into a small that's so cool I'm
really glad if oh whoa whoa ramming
dildo incoming I'm woah woah suicide
bombers oh my god oh I'm really glad
that they they've continually updated
this game because they keep adding new
stuff this game is always going to be
cool I mean it's cool right now but oh
hang on I'll get to you Bowser your
fire-breathing skills ain't no match for
mine hubba hubba
how about oh you just want a face full
of fire tea oh no oh your gum oh that's
right to add it in the key wait there
was a key at the beginning of the level
too so if I go all the way back oh I
might as well finish this one off in
style cuz there was another key all the
way over here or another keyhole oh
that's so cool
that is so cool really wouldn't
I can probably I could probably just
spend through that nope alright
Oh God okay but this one I'm okay good
we're fine we're fine everything's cool
everything's cool so this one over here
there was one I was right yeah cuz this
is definitely been added in I don't
remember this ever be yeah okay yes I
don't know if they said anything
different than the other one because how
would I have anything to compare it to
oh please do not make me die oh no [ __ ]
I'm not I'm not in bigan ated okay if I
go back through the door I should be
able to get back to nah but there's a
bonus right there I can get it I'm good
I still want to die Oh in charge oh
that's so cool ah hey you want some of
me you wizard fun Oh dodged me huh you
ain't gonna dodge what are you gonna
dodge this outfit you dodged it huh I'm
gonna say that you dodged did it not
that I missed because one oh my god it
said oh my god that's so cool I could
have just killed him at any time
oh that's so cool I know I know I know I
say that a lot but for a final level
this really cool this really cool should
be able to there we go there's my Yosh
come on yo [ __ ] we're gonna go places
and do things and I don't know what
exactly we're gonna do but we're gonna
do it good yep
okay nevermind then that was a dead end
good for us well I'm gonna trust this
arrow that isn't just gonna drop us into
the abyss yep
oh okay we're fine Oh what what I need
to go here whoops ah ah no Bowser ah oh
Bowser you bully [ __ ] I didn't know
that I just needed to go through there
that would have been fine I could have
gone there in the beginning I thought oh
I thought I was gonna hide it like a
special secret by just being at the
beginning of the game load an ass
hey Bowser guess what you suck
da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da okay yay okay
that's cool and that is the end of the
hundred Mario challenge so let's see if
it give me any special bonus and the
next time I'm gonna play the expert
hundred Mario challenge because that
could lead to a lot more cool scenarios
I might also do normal again because
there's some pretty cool normal ones out
here up but up Bubba whoa I got the
record yeah I'm awesome look at me look
at me oh boy
Mario it's terrible Princess Peach has
been taken to another castle Oh God who
knew always and forever
that poor girl yep just end on sadness
that's all - gonna be oh and this is all
the people that made it okay
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to see more of
Super Mario maker I'm going to be doing
like the hundred mario challenges for a
while now because it offers a lot of
variety but also if there's cool levels
that you guys want to see let me know in
the comments below thank you again
everybody so much for watching
oh cool and as always I will see you in
the next video
you have a weird life